hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round seven of the
2018 candidates tournament here we have
a Sergey Kerrigan with the white pieces
and Wesley soul with the black pieces
now I was very amazed by what happened
in this game I don't know if you've seen
it or not by all means do share your
opinions in the comment section as
Wesley had a had a not the greatest
tournament so far but he did beat beat
11 Oregon in in the previous round so
he's very satisfied with himself and now
obviously after seeing this game he kind
of does play for for the draw with the
black pieces and Sergey kurakin
definitely isn't having the tournament
of his life as he is the 2016 challenger
to Magnus Carlsen
so naturally you'd expect him to do well
in the 2018 candidates tournament but I
mean it's really really weird what
happens in this game you'll just have to
see it and before before we start I do
have two photos from this game here we
have a nice photo of Sergey Kerrigan I
mean he does look kind of weird I don't
know what's so wrong with him but he
doesn't look like the usual Sergey Kirk
and maybe he changed his hair and other
than this we have a photo of the two of
them here we have what's the sauce
sipping his beverage and kurakin
pondering on the position so let's see
this game kurakin opens wood d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 and East six now Knight
to c3 and Bishop to b4 so the names o
Indian defense we have III castles
Knight to f3 and d5 Drago's in variation
of the names Oh Bishop to d2 now c5 a3
Bishop cap sorry C captures on d4 a
captures Bishop on b4 and now D captures
on c3 Bishop captures on c3 and D
captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and
immediately picnic of the Queen's Queen
captures and now King captures our
characters is also possible depends
which you prefer Bishop to d7 because
white definitely isn't interested in
castling so it doesn't matter if he
captures would the king
Bishop to d7 king-tv to now and rook to
c8 attacking the bishop Bishop to d3 and
now we have Knight to d5 Knight to e5
attacking the bishop on d7 bishop moves
back to e8 and now Bishop to d2 I'm
allowing black tech to alleviate white
of the bishop pair f6 kicking the night
night to see Knight to c4 and now rook
to d8 black doesn't want to allow rock
to d6 here we have rook H to c1 and
Knight to c6 Bishop to e4 Knight capture
some before Bishop capture some before
and Knight capture some before seems
like white just lost upon here but not
really white actually wins upon
Bishop captures zombie salmon with with
the attack on the rook rook to b8 and
now rook captures on a7 and here for the
moment Kerrigan is up a pawn but rock to
d7 attacking the bishop of course Knight
to a5 defending it and now Knight to d3
attacking the rook and c1 and here a
kurakin plays rook to d1 rook to c2 is
also possible but after Bishop to g6
this rook will have to move eventually
and the black will win the B to pawn so
kirkin doesn't even bother defending yet
he plays rook to d1 with a double attack
on the night and now Knight capture some
b2 again attacking the rook on d1 rook
captures on d7 Bishop captures on d7 and
Bishop to c6 now forcing even more
exchanges Bishop captures Knight
captures attacking the rook on unbe 8
and here rook to e8 and this rook to e8
is a is a pretty big mistake by Wesley
so and this will this will come back to
haunt him later in the game the reason
is here after seeing this position you
have to realize that the rook is
covering the a8 where the knight
discovering b8 and the d8 and c8 is
currently of pretty much no importance
as the king will definitely come up the
board and protect the knight on c6
so definitely a move like rook to b6
getting the rook to an active square
would have been better but okay what's
the place rook to e8 and now we have a
four-night the c4 King to d3 kurakin
wants to get his King
Knight to d6 and now f4 we have King to
f8 Wesley also wants to activate his
King but now II 5f characters on e5 f
captures on e5 attacking the knight
Knight to f5 and now g4 again pressuring
the knight Knight comes to h4 and now
kink the c5 and now as you can see the
material is completely calm on the board
it seems that black will have some
counter play after going Knight to f3
attacking the pawn and maybe they might
can pick off one of these 2 points or
after going Knight to f3 attack the h1
and the e5 pawn but you'll see that at
this position is pretty much hopeless
for black because you have to see that
the rook is covering the 8 square
c8 spurs of no much important not much
importance for the rogue because the
King can simply defend the night here
the knight also covers d8 square and
this rook has no way of becoming active
so R up to b6 and that that position was
extremely important here Knight to f3
attacking the h2 pawn and first rock
back to a 2 not pushing h3 to allow
night did you want to attack the point
even further here rook the c8 we have
King to see a king to b5 with defending
the knight and now King to e8 and this
King to e8 is the final nail in the
coffin so to say here it was extremely
important to play rook to c7 and for
some reason Wesley missed this I think
it's because Wesley was basically going
for a draw this game he he was satisfied
with the drawing he thought this game
was indeed drawn but here rook to see
someone was an extremely important move
because this is the only moment in the
game I mean not the only but the last
moment in the game you have a chance to
activate your work now we're talking b6
you have worked to d7 and you do have
somewhat of an active rook if this rook
comes to check you go to f7 and and it's
all it's all ok but after this King to
b5 Wesley played King to e8 wanting to
improve the King's activity even further
but now it's all over now
kink the b6 and now this rock really
doesn't have any Square to go to here g5
was played
we have h3 and now black is basically
enthused wonk there's really no move you
can make here you can't really move the
King if you play something like King to
f8 going back then rook to f2 this
simply wins apiece if you try something
like King to d7 then you get a rope to
a7 check King moves and now simply rock
captures on h7 with the threat of rook
to h8 there's no way to defend this rook
black would have to give up the exchange
here and white is completely winning in
this position
so after h3 there really isn't anything
to do here black could waste one more
move with h6 but this doesn't achieve
anything simply rook rook to a7 with the
threat of rook to e6 rook to e7 check
picking up this pawn or if if the King
moves simply rook to h7 and then pick up
all the points on the Kings side but you
don't even have to trouble yourself even
the the brute King to be 7 wins the game
now there's no way you can move this
rook after game 37 now comes Knight the
b8 check kinked idiot and now rook to e8
threatening Knight to c6 opening up a
discovered attack from the rook also
checking the black King and winning a
full rook
so here black would have to capture and
if you capture this King moves now look
to h8 and after Knight captures on e5
you capture on h6 and now you have two
points and the rook against two pawns
and the knight a winning position for
white but after this h3 move Wesley
didn't even want to go into any of these
endings where he has a knight against
the rook maybe trying to hold this he
just played Knight captures on e5 it's a
it's definitely a weird decision I don't
know if he missed something or or what
happened here but you know trying to
hold night against the Brooklyn two
pawns seems like a more reasonable
choice than then playing Knight captures
on e5 but again I haven't seen the live
coverage I don't know if he missed
something or was there some plan to this
but okay Cara can simply captured it
we have rope the c3 Wesley goes for the
h3 pawn we have rook to h2 defending it
King to e7
and now after King to b5
rook to e3 after this robbery to remove
Wesley resigned the game I mean there's
no point in continuing it you have a
pawn for four or nine months that's like
no compensation whatsoever white will
simply move the knight and there's
really nothing black and hope for here
so yeah after this rook to e3 move
what will resign the game and a nice
victory for Sergei kurakin he definitely
isn't having the tournament of his life
but you know a victory in this first
half of the tournament at least one will
will definitely give him something
something to look forward to so yeah a
very interesting game although I mean
the Queen's did come off the board like
really really early in the game and I
think that the reason Wesley missed this
idea of Kerrigan being if simply being
to active was because he was actually
playing for a draw if he was trying to
play the best moves I don't think he
would have lost this game but that's
what happens you get that win against
Arnon in the previous round now you lose
a game like this against kurakin and
that rook the c7 move isn't like
something a 2,800 player would miss but
yeah I mean I just think it's a weird
game so if any of you have any more
insight to this do share in the comments
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it once again I would like to thank
Nikki for her photos from this event
from the 2018 candidates tournament as
usual all of the links to our social
media will be in the description below
I feel free to check out some of our
some of her work and yeah that's it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here I will make both of them
from the candidates thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with a nice game by vasily von
Schuch as it is his birthday today thank
you all